[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy quiero compartir una historia hace
cinco años me encontré parado frente a
un salón de clases lleno de adolescentes
pues tenía pocos meses de trabajar como
maestro mi inicio fue en el área de
tecnología
ya que le había aplicado bien por
algunos años y se encuentra directamente
relacionada con la carrera de ingeniería
uno de estos días impartiendo una clase
de dispositivos móviles
la clase fluía de una manera excepcional
pues hoy en día los chicos son expertos
en esta rama a unos cuantos minutos la
clase ya tenía buenas participaciones y
argumentos sobre algunas características
de algunas marcas que yo les pedía
al cierre el objetivo que yo tenía para
estos chicos ya lo habían alcanzado un
acercamiento a las fichas técnicas sobre
los componentes y los sensores que
tienen dichos dispositivos
entonces fue así como empecé a trabajar
con los muchachos te platico
me sorprendió que un pequeño grupo se
esperara al final de la clase
y en susurros se ponían a platicar para
ver si me contaban lo que tenían entre
manos pues era secreto
los chicos
tenían querían hacer un proyecto
que querían hacer
ellos querían interactuar con un
software que habían descargado de
internet y pretendían construir una
cabina una cabina de auto para así
formar lo que es un simulador de auto de
fórmula uno
parece como verdad pero estos chicos ya
tenían todo ordenado
sólo estaban buscando algunos espacios
la primera de diseñar la otra de
construir y la siguiente de programar
tenían que ir por la programación de una
placa que interactuar ya con un sensor
de giroscopio que justamente vimos ese
día en la clase
fue ahí donde los chicos desbordaron en
la emoción
qué pasa cuando descubres un nuevo
conocimiento quiero invitarte a eso te
invito por favor que puedas traer a tu
mente ya sea algún amigo algún maestro
o algún jefe tuyo que te haya podido
ayudar a comprender un tema o que te
ayuda a enseñar a hacer un trabajo mejor
si es así lo traes ahorita
estoy seguro que entenderá la alegría de
estos jóvenes
trabajando en esta parte
yo cuestioné dos cosas la primera el
compromiso que tienen estos chicos por
su proyecto
pues ya tenían días trabajando con ellos
y se habían atorado en esta parte
la segunda el compromiso que yo estaba
iniciando en el área de la educación
como ya lo comenté la historia tenía
pocos meses
fue ahí donde se equilibraron las dos
cosas la primera maestro
alumnos
y fue ahí donde decidimos
y no descansar traer esa idea que se
encontraba en sus ipad a través de
diseños y breves descripciones no
descansar de traerlo de ese formato
digital a este mundo real
empezamos a acordar donde nos estaríamos
viendo pudimos coincidir solamente
durante el recreo y pasó el primer
recreo el segundo y el tercero y que es
difícil que los jóvenes se puedan
entregar aquello que más les gusta tú
sabes el recreo
entonces nos reuníamos día con día así
por lo largo de un mes poco más
donde los chicos vivieron y disfrutaron
cada una de sus etapas
diseñaron
produjeron pequeñas maquetas de ahí
decidieron y tuvieron la oportunidad de
equivocarse
al ir por cual diseño aplicar en la
construcción unos cortaban unos pintaban
otros adaptaban y reciclaban piezas que
ni siquiera aún teníamos en ese entonces
pues no estábamos equipados pero la
parte de programación todos dejaban de
hacer y dejaban de hacer para aprender
aquello que los había detenido iban a
las computadoras
y empezaban a relacionarse con un
lenguaje nuevo un lenguaje de
programación
estos chicos lograron concretar un
proyecto decente
y claro tuvieron su nota académica
vamos a decir excelente y pudieron
compartirlo dentro del salón pero estaba
faltando algo
algo que cambiará la parte del chip en
la parte de cómo se ven los proyectos
pero es aún pero una gran oportunidad
que tuvieron fue de conocer a un piloto
de fórmula uno
que con retroalimentación
y con pequeñas descripciones donde le
daba valor al proyecto de estos chicos
los hizo encontrar su centro
en las descripciones les decía yo puedo
utilizar tu simulador como una
herramienta para poder practicar cuando
el clima no me lo permita también puedo
utilizarlo para extender mi periodo de
práctica o estar practicando en una
pista que se encuentra al otro lado del
mundo
ellos tenían el compromiso de regresar a
la escuela y compartirlo con las demás
aulas pero no llegaron igual porque el
aprendizaje había cambiado a un
aprendizaje significativo
fue ahí
donde yo pude notar el cambio de estos
chicos ahora llegaban y exponían y esto
esto ya no era un proyecto sino que era
un movimiento se sentía en el centro los
jóvenes
y pudieron motivar a otros a mi espacio
a los siguientes días llegaban y tocaban
a la puerta y decían tengo una idea que
compartir y junto con la idea yo anotaba
la descripción la necesidad que tenía
ese proyecto
puede llevarla al centro educativo y
compartirla con mis directivos
fue ahí donde reunieron a los chicos y
les plantearon la propuesta de hacer un
taller de robótica
lo que nos contestaron ya los estábamos
esperando ellos ya estaban preparados
a esto se le añadió
más chicos con más pasión más talento y
el crecimiento exponencial se daba día
con día
pues generaron hacer un cambio un en
cada un cambio que empezó con algo
pequeño
que nos deja esta historia esta historia
nos deja que estos chicos pudieron bajar
un contenido que en aquel entonces hace
5 años a lo mejor el exclusivo solamente
de universidades
se capacitó
y se pudo bajar un contenido de acuerdo
a sus sociedades
hoy en día han formado un techo pero un
techo firme ese techo firme que sirve
como segundo piso a las siguientes
generaciones hoy comparten este espacio
de robótica con niños de primaria
secundaria jóvenes de primaria pero
niños de primaria
jóvenes
y chicos de prepa
que nos deja esto
esto nos deja qué
nuestra cultura ya está preparada para
dar nuevos saltos
yo les pregunto a mis chicos qué te
gusta del taller de robótica
y sus respuestas redundan en lo
siguiente me dice la verdad a mí lo que
me atrapa son los retos y me gusta
aprender a través de ellos
la siguiente me dicen yo soy alguien que
puede aquí expresar creatividad y vengo
a aportar a esto al taller
la otra me dicen me siento dentro de un
entorno seguro ese entorno seguro donde
sé que puedo fallar o acertar
pero no lo voy a ver reflejado con una
equis o con una palomita sino que es el
mismo reto quien me dice que estoy
facultado y he aprendido
y cosas nuevas
tiene contacto directo con otras
asignaturas idiomas español
ciencias tecnología formación cívica y
ética
estos señores es aprendizaje transversal
ellos pueden estar echando mano de lo
que aprendieron ayer nos ni siquiera el
año pasado
y vuelto en la cultura de la ser se
vuelve un aprendizaje cognitivo ese
aprendizaje cognitivo cuando se derrama
en un proyecto se vuelve en un montón de
habilidades para la vida nuestros niños
nuestros jóvenes están preparados para
solucionar en este mundo real
quiero decirte algo es una pregunta
cuánto del porcentaje de tus
conocimientos se están quedando en
teóricos
y abstractos y no estoy diciendo que lo
teórico y lo abstracto no sea necesario
claro que se ocupa pero si no estamos
generando espacios para él hacer déjame
decirte que tus proyectos la mayoría se
estarán deteniendo en su etapa digital
nuestros niños hoy en día están
intentando
solucionar problemas del mundo e
intentan compartirlo y compartirlo bien
ellos intentan llevar llevar un servicio
ofertar un producto
o transmitir una idea que pueda alcanzar
por lo menos su entorno el local
y posteriormente
cambiar el mundo
quiero compartir texto este año nuestros
chicos nos dejaron sorprendidos porque
estuvimos dedicándonos un poco más a
brindar este tipo de espacios
inmediatamente de ver contenidos se
abren espacios para poder producir que
de aquello que con lo cual se informan
que es lo que producen nos pudieron
sorprender en el área de ciencia y
tecnología lograron pasar los tres
equipos que se presentaron
plata para la etapa local la etapa
regional dos de ellos pudieron llegar a
la nacional y hoy en día nos
sorprendemos porque han alcanzado temas
internacionales
quiero cerrar con esto
brindemos en las escuelas nuevos
espacios para el aprendizaje que
involucrarán todos los contenidos que ya
se abarcan
pero sin embargo
tenemos que involucrarlos donde sea un
espacio muy parecido a los de un trabajo
real
porque es así dónde se va a dar las
partes del trabajo individual del
trabajo colaborativo pero sobre todo
van a encontrar aquello que les apasiona
y van a poder compartirlo desde ese
centro que quiero que conozcan
este es mi mensaje espero que les haya
agradado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]